We're gonna head over to the area with the snacks that will
be appearing very shortly.
Shortly.
Yippee!
Aw, you guys.
It's so nice.
Can you see us?
What is the girl scout cookies thing?
Someone was like, what about girl scout cookies?
What are they?
He's made through child labor But no, but delicious, but
they're delicious.
Okay.
Also, yeah, first MVP of collab.
Whoa.
What is this shit?
It's a friend.
These are the legs and then the arms and then the ears.
Oh, yeah.
What are you guys interested for us to try first?
Because we have, yeah, we have a bit of a array of both
American and British snacks.
Although I do think that for some of the British stuff, we
definitely want a nice cup of tea with it.
Definitely want a nice cup of tea.
A cup of tea.
I had so much I bought, all in a nice Trader Joe's bag as
well.
I got to the airport and my housemate called me and she was
like, DeeDee, you left your entire Trader Joe's bag.
You left.
No, no.
So I wonder if we bought some of the same things.
It's what time, 11 a.m.
Snack time.
Oh, sorry.
So, a British staple.
You're a kid in the UK.
You've got your sandwich and you've got your Monster Munch
Pickled Onion.
Monster Munch Pickled Onion?
These are pretty strong flavored.
Okay.
But you guys can see if you like them.
Let's open them and find out.
I want to smell it.
Yeah, smell the bag.
Smell the bag.
It just smells like pickles.
Whoa.
It just smells like a real pickle.
They don't look like the...
Are they shaped funny?
Yeah, they don't look like pickles.
a bag at all like a this thing oh they do they do yeah they
shaped like little monster feet they're more orangy on the
back oh they're feet and feet oh i thought they were teeth
or something no no if we interlocked toes like oh he used to
eat the whole thing in one bite yeah oh you like you like
you like a monster one pickled onion oh
That's good!
Yeah, right?
It's like quite a, it's a very distinct flavour, but this is
a British staple, guys.
If you like a Monster Munch Pickled Onion, if you want, you
can probably have UK citizenship.
It's...
Oh!
So I'm...
We're British.
British.
Next, slightly weird one.
Twiglets.
Okay, so twiglets.
They are twigs in a bag.
Twigs in a bag.
Yes.
They taste, I think they're Marmites.
Marmite.
Oh no.
It was Marmite.
I've had Vegemite.
Vegemite.
Read it in the back real quick.
Crunchy, savory whole wheat sticks.
Savory huh?
Savory.
Entertain your senses.
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Only twiglets give you that distinctive nobly shape.
Nobly shape.
Combined with a zingy taste and crunchy bite for all
brownies.
sensual satisfaction sensual
Whoa damn twiglets everybody it's twiglets okay imagine
you're in the woods oh they really look like sticks you're
in the woods you got nothing else to eat and you see some
some twigs on the floor now go for it try one so forced very
poor that's all but i i'm kind of scared it looks just like
a a twig it does doesn't it yeah look at that oh some of
them are nastier looking than others they've been in the mud
longer whoa it's kind of bitter whoa oh yes oh yes wow you
know what it tastes like what i would expect a stick to
taste like yeah so actually it's it's it's completely
accurate advertising.
Seems like excellent reviews all round, I think.
For the Monster Munch, why did you guys vote the first one?
Well, we need to give our ratings out of 10.
Out of 10?
There was a 10 out of 10.
Yeah, I think it was 10.
Okay, a slightly different scale then.
How about the twiglets for these?
It's got an accurate twig shape.
Which is fun.
I find myself winning seconds.
Really?
Yeah.
Whoa!
Is that gonna thrill?
Three, maybe, maybe.
It's high in fiber.
I think I am a little sensualized.
You know, I will try one more.
Maybe I'll be able to accurately see how I feel about it.
Five.
Five out of ten.
It's not terrible, but I would not eat this willingly.
Yeah.
It's not terrible, but you would not eat it willingly.
They could definitely put that on the packaging, I think.
Howdy, I'm ready to eat my American snakes, Jenny.
I'm Victoria Roman.
And I'm ready.
Here we go.
Da da da da da da da da da da da da da.
Da da da da da da da da da da.
Oh wait, where is it?
Gush.
It is.
Have you ever like seen cartoon jewels in like, and like
you've been like, wow, that looks delicious.
I want to eat that.
Oh, like a kale salad?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Whoa, they're all red.
Look at all of them.
They're all red.
I'm gonna taste it.
Do it.
Mmm.
It wasn't much gushing.
There wasn't much actual liquid inside.
Oh, there wasn't.
Maybe I'll try another one.
Yeah, try another one.
Keep going.
Oh, a little bit more in that one.
Oh, yeah.
I guess it depends.
But the gushers.
Does it taste like America?
America.
It tastes like America.
It tastes like the land of the free, the gusher.
Are we doing honest reviews?
Yeah.
The strawberry flavor is a little bit like fake strawberry
flavor.
Oh, oh.
America.
could have done with more gushing action.
Four out of ten.
I'm sorry.
Oh, mine didn't gush either.
Yeah, yeah.
I will say, wait, actually, before you give your final
thoughts.
Yes.
Mr. Gusher is my uncle.
Wait, like, legit?
Cool.
Yeah.
So would you please, would you like to?
Phoebe's face.
That's great, really?
Yes, I would very much like to retract my statement.
I'm so sorry for insulting your family.
I'd like to reconsider and go for a solid seven out of 10.
Or should I?
We used to have these in the UK too.
Oh really?
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Yeah, not.
Okay, here we go.
Does this look familiar?
Shall we extend it?
Whoa.
It looks like a tongue.
I used to do that.
I could like feed it to feed it.
I also wasn't allowed to have much of this as a kid either.
So this is fine, not fine.
Should I just eat it?
I need to keep going.
I need to keep rolling.
Yeah, okay.
We're gonna keep rolling.
I'm trying to keep up.
Are we actually doing Lady in the Tram?
Yeah.
Should I split here so that you can also...
See to me, it tastes way better than the gushes.
I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really like the flavor.
There's something like I said, it's so thin too.
Yeah, it's just like, if it was thicker, I feel like it
wouldn't be as satisfying.
This is good stuff.
Oh, that's so nice.
That's a solid eight.
Whoa.
Solid eight for the foot.
is called foot that is called foot you know for v2 for fans
i'll show you understand that that is uh that's your point
so good foot out of 10.
love it so good this is a classic uk flavor crisp yeah yeah
skips skips are so good all right go for it go for it go for
a skip is this just a shrimp chip hold on i'm gonna i'm
gonna have it
A shrimp chip of texture.
The flavor.
The flavor, it has the cocktail a little bit.
That's yummy.
Oh, I would admit.
Do your crisps well.
I will admit that they taste less flavorful than they did
when I was a kid.
Uh oh.
I feel like they used to be more like coated in the powder.
It's hard times.
Hard times, yeah.
In which case, I think this is like a good, it's like eight
or?
Yeah, I was gonna say a seven or eight for me.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, seven or eight, yeah, six or seven.
They're very easy to eat, though.
No!
Can I just go?
Can I just...
Oh!
I've seen this guy.
I've seen them before.
I've never had them, though.
And it's specifically mint flavored.
Yeah, mint flavored.
The peppermint era ice.
Did you get peppermint flavor for, like, specifically,
because that's the best one?
I mean, personally, I would have gone for the regular, but
Steiner bought these.
Oh, so, yeah.
Right, right.
But wait, can we just eat the whole thing?
Yeah, we can.
Oh, it looks like you could break it apart.
Oh, or you could break it apart.
I mean, if you wanna do that, you can break one apart.
If you wanna, I mean, there's lots of snacks still to come.
Yes.
Are you guys the kind of person that like separates your
chocolates that have like, you know, these markings, or do
you just like bite into it like a heathen?
There's no judgment either way.
I think I bite into it like a heathen.
Yeah.
It depends.
Oh, it smells good.
It does smell good.
Ooh.
It's very pretty.
Yeah, look guys.
Look at that.
It is literally like the colors of your outfit, Mint Dog.
You like it?
I really like it.
Oh!
Big, big, big ups from Phoebe over here.
You can't, you know, you can't go above 10 out of 10 if it's
something that you really feel deserves it.
You can go to like a 15, yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh, that's good to know.
It just melts.
I love that half crystal.
That's like a bubble bath.
And I don't know why it makes me envision a bubble bath in
my brain.
No, these are good.
Never mind.
Maybe I do like these better than the original era.
They're so good.
Wait, I want to have the whole thing.
I think we should compare peppermints.
I know.
With peppermints, I brought the Girl Scout thin mints.
This is like probably one of the most popular, what'd you
say, the most popular Girl Scouts?
This and like Camoas.
I feel like a coconut chocolate one.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
But yeah, you got your like little Girl Scout.
They're like, we're, we're entrepreneurs.
And they, we teach you how to.
We're women in STEM.
Yeah, we're women in STEM.
Oh yeah, literally says STEM.
Oh.
Go ahead and try the skin meat.
okay these are made these are made by the Girl Scouts so any
if I insult this I'm insulting all of the Girl Scouts for
America yeah I don't like it okay every little girl with
hopes and dreams are in that cookie I wish you could see
Minnie's face oh no you don't have to force yourself you
don't have to force yourself it tastes like I've stuck my
face in a bonfire what it tastes like to me it very smoky
why does it taste smoky i think i understand what you mean
by sticking your face in the bonfire you know what i mean
like when that was my first the first thing that hit my
tongue i feel bad because when i say that i imagine little
minto the brownie outfit i feel like i'm insulting little
minto you know if i say that these are on a 10 out of 10.
no don't give me that basement though minto's doing like the
the pussy boots from shrek I like sticking my face in the
bonfire.
I mean, I've always wanted to try a Girl Scout cookie, so
I'm very grateful.
I gotta bring you other ones next time.
I'm very grateful to Little Minto.
They're very expensive, that's the thing too.
Oh, really?
We're not very, but like $8 for a box.
Yeah, it's like $8 for a box.
$8?
Yeah.
I mean, for the cookie itself, I'm sorry, it's a 5 out of
10.
I'm sorry to all the Girl Scouts of America.
I'm sorry Roast beef Roast munch I've never had these So
it's going to be as much of a surprise for me as it is for
you guys Whoa Oh dear Oh no I can't tell this is good or bad
reaction Like a roast beef but the texture is not what the
roast beef should be Oh Oh Phoebe's a fan I'm not gonna lie
I don't like the smell of it So we'll see what I think about
He's got a very negative looking reaction.
See?
It felt, it seems like that, right.
It's strange.
No, bro, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All you, Phoebe, all you.
They're mine.
I can't believe I'm saying this.
This is gonna be my lowest rating of the day.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Lower than Swiglitz?
And of the American sex as well, this is my lowest rating so
far.
I'm giving that a solid two.
Two.
No, bro.
The initial taste is so weird.
There's not a weird aftertaste.
One sip makes laugh.
One more sip makes happy and relaxed moments.
240 tea.
Can we see 240 tea bags?
Can we open it?
Yorkshire tea, fresh box unboxing.
Here we go.
Now this is the kind of content that British people are
like, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh, look at that.
It's just all stacked in there.
It just be like that.
I've never had a Yorkshire tea.
you will love it you guys i don't know what these are i've
never tried them but i thought this sounded very american
because like corn is the staple crop of our of our cornbread
crisps cornbread crisps sweet and salted cornbread snake.
Enjoy the flavor of freshly baked corn bread wherever you
are without turning on the oven.
Made with a fragrant cornmeal and a touch of sea salt, these
slightly sweet take anywhere snacks are baked to a golden
crisp.
Crumble them into soup or salad for added crunch, serve
alongside warm chili, cream cheese, dip them or simply eat
by the hand.
Oh, I don't smell anything.
I don't smell like anything.
Oh yeah, can I smell?
Yeah, go for it.
I mean, so Trader Joe's does really good at snacks, but I
will try these.
These have been really good with some cheese.
Yeah.
Yeah, right, right?
I say, oh, I taste the cornbread now.
Dude, that's like legit cornbread.
Is that even like the little residue that cornbread has?
Trader Joe's does not disappoint.
No.
Those are lovely.
These are good, right?
These are really good.
What?
I think those are my favorite so far out of everything.
What was the highest rating I gave?
Quite low.
Those are the best so far.
Trader Joe's, Julie.
That is really nice.
The color.
This is the proper color that you will have your tea.
Even this is slightly too light for me because I'm taking it
easy, you know, because we don't want to give it like, you
know, too dark.
That is an acceptable colour, everyone.
Right now that we've got a fresh tea to dip, everyone, we're
going in for the holy brick.
Who?
The one and the only hobnobs.
Now, I had to really...
Hobnobs!
I had to try very hard not to eat these before today's
stream.
I kept dreaming of the hobnobs that I knew were in the bag.
I kept thinking, oh, I must not eat the hobnobs.
knows it took a lot of determination and then let me teach
you the uh the technique okay okay yes yes okay i want to
have a nice dip about halfway don't dip too much otherwise
the biscuit will start to break very nice very nice okay i'm
a hobnobber you're a hobnobber oh you guys gonna like these
penguin biscuit guys what are these penguin it's just called
penguin penguin each of them have jokes on them or they
should oh yeah you'll get to have a stupid joke on your
biscuit as well what's a penguin's favorite film what frozen
i know uh these i i mean I feel like the jokes are the more
appealing part.
Like the biscuits are fine.
Ow.
I like it.
No, you like it?
Mm-hmm.
No.
We'll do this.
This is also from Trader Joe's.
Trader Joe's.
I've also never had this before, but I think I just wanted
corn everything.
Corn failed us so far.
I feel like those corn breads are going to take some beans.
That was so good.
Dark chocolate covered crunchy corn curds.
corn kernels straight from the farmer these look strange
why they powdered like that yeah they smell kind of funky
they do smell okay so looks alone it does look a bit like
animal poop of some sort but i'm gonna give it a go it's
like It tastes like what you would expect, I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like exactly what is advertised.
It doesn't taste good nor bad.
The flavors, I get that they're trying to go for like salty
sweet, but the flavors just don't match each other at all.
It doesn't feel like they're together.
It feels like you're eating things separate from the color.
The key problem I have is the dog chocolate is really...
Gross?
Yeah.
I was like...
Oh yeah.
It's an American chocolate.
Sorry.
It's really strange tasting.
Like, you can tell it's dog chocolate.
but it's like really really old yeah tastes expired um yeah
am i gonna bring out a one whoa i surely can't can i you
can't bring out a one you're allowed to yeah that's what
that's why the scale's there all right guys have you ever
had what cherry bakewell that's so cute mr kipley cherry
bakewells and now now this now this guys this is the stuff
exceedingly good Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, yummy.
Maybe Phoebe's highest rating, yeah, from that thing.
It's nice to wash it down with some tea.
It is good with the tea.
I don't know, I think maybe it's a tad too sweet.
With the tea, it's pee.
Yes, Phoebe!
I get it.
Why are you letting that tea with everything?
Yes, Phoebe!
Dunk, dunk was this?
Dunkaroos!
I've never had these before, but my friend was like, if you
are bringing American snack, you must bring Dunkaroos!
Whoa!
Dunkaroos, what's your dunk?
The Dunkwich or the Dunkin' Scoop?
Oh, it's like the ways to dunk, I see.
Wow.
So what is the, what is the sauce with it?
It looks like it's like birthday cake flavor.
It's some kind of icing.
We're dunking.
Okay.
Whoa.
Is that a good amount of dunk?
No, it looks like, yeah.
All right.
It's just frosting, I think.
Oh.
It took a second to process.
I remember a pop top.
Ah.
I like pop top.
I'm a big fan of pop top.
The cookies are a lot smaller than I thought they were.
I know, right?
No, I saw it.
Eight out of ten.
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
I like it.
That's tasty.
Yeah, they taste like cheese.
but it's compelling is what someone said.
I don't know if this was a good idea, but we've got one of
the sweetest things now.
Oh boy.
Now this, this is something specifically I think I asked
Steiner to order because it's not super easily available.
Yeah, okay.
So let me explain the law behind this stuff.
Kendall mint cake.
Yeah, so.
Yeah, yeah.
So this stuff is like, originally it's kind of, it's like
quite a traditional thing.
for hikers to give them like a sugar boost when they're like
walking the Yorkshire Dales and all that or walking I think
this it's technically in the lake so like the lake district
so they're walking walking the lakes hiking around to give
them like an energy boost and my dad always used to give us
this while we were out like hiking stuff and we were like oh
my god it's so good so is it white chocolate no it's mint
it's literally just blocks of mint sugary mint yeah it's so
good What the heck is that?
It's like a block, it's just like a block of sugary mint.
Holy cow.
It's so good.
All right, you probably won't want more than this each, to
be honest with you.
Oh, it smells very...
Oh, it looks so young.
It feels young.
Okay, when people say that they're eating, not eating
peppermint is like eating toothpaste.
Yeah.
This is like eating solid toothpaste.
Maybe that's what I like.
I used to eat toothpaste as a kid.
I like it though.
No, I'm not going to lie.
This is my fab of the whole day.
I love this stuff.
It's so good.
My brain is so confused.
Like, it's like yummy.
And texturally, it like makes me really happy.
But then the mint flavor is so, so, so strong.
I'm brushing my teeth.
I like it.
10 out of 10.
10 out of 10!
Honestly, I might.
Just because it's so unique to you, I might go above and go
for like a 12 out of 10 from me.
Uniqueness?
Definitely.
Well, let's put it out like a, for me, I'm putting it out
like a seven.
Okay.
I'll take a seven.
It's so, it's got such a nice texture.
I love the texture.
It's like, yeah.
Saving something good for the finale.
Okay.
This is the British snack finale, guys.
Is there any more American snacks?
Nope.
Mm-mm.
This is the last one.
Finale of the finalis.
a Jaffa cake.
A Jaffa cake.
Wasn't there like a debate about how to classify Jaffa
cakes?
Yes, I think so.
Like whether they were a biscuit or a cake.
Yes, that was.
What was the conclusion?
Do you know?
I don't know, but they're good.
Cry.
It's got chocolate on.
Here we go.
Yeah, it's chocolate and then an orange tangy center.
The only thing that makes it remotely biscuit-like is just
like the crunch of the chocolate, but that's not the thing
itself.
I think also like the shape of it makes me want to be like,
oh yeah, this is a cookie, right?
No, this is a toy.
We can say the results.
The winner of the savory category is Team USA Cornbread
Crisp.
Yeah!
But the winner of the sweet category.
I would say maybe it's a toss up between Kendall Mint Cake
and Cherry Bake Roll.
Let's say the mint cake, because like, I'm a Jordan.
Yeah, I think they could be a joint winner.
And the winner of the sweet section, joint winners, Team
United Kingdom, Kendall Mint Cake, and Cherry Bake Wells.
Yeah!
Thank you everyone, thank you for joining the first MVP of
Colab.
Thank you!
Wait, is it, oh, oh, there it is.
Sorry.
Yummy!
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.
Goodbye everyone.
Bye.